je pense que le maquereau nisme est
quelque chose de compliqué il a
énormément d'intelligence
c'est un peu un prodige de la politique
qu'un de ce point de vue là il a compris
d'ailleurs la communication ce qui fait
que il est capable d'interpréter un
certain nombre de rôles successivement
en revanche je pense qu'il a eu il est
très manichéen dans sa façon de voir les
choses
il dit la ville de l'est au rivage run
justement ils dynamitent le clivage
droite gauche mais en même temps il
réinstalle un autre clivage entre lui et
les autres lui et les extrêmes
c'est pas un hyper centrisme c'est
plutôt à un auto un égocentrisme si
j'ose dire et c'est ça qui est gênant
s'il ya des familles de pensée qui sont
des grandes polarités depuis des années
des années et il peut pas lui seul les
récapituler il aimerait justement faire
en sorte qu' il est le camp du bien
quand du progrès et le camp du mal et ça
c'est quelque chose qui me gêne